welcome to day two of the data driven
decision processes boot camp i'm along
one of the research fellows for this
program
and the overall theme for the day to day
is going to be reinforcement learning
so to start off we have professor
veenawang from cmu talking about the
fundamentals of markov decision
processes
i think i have a microphone here
yeah thank you for the introduction and
also thank the organizers for putting
together this great program i'm really
excited for the semester so i'm glad to
start the series of tutorial today what
i'm going to cover in the first part
which is the first hour uh are the very
basics of markov decision processes
so i know many of you in the audience
are experts so this is going to be a
little bit slow for you but i'm hoping
to put everyone on an eco footing here
okay
so uh let's get started so what is the
mdp i'm going to just write on my ipad
this is something i learned during the
pandemic okay so let's first look at an
example so we are playing a game which i
call simple mario party um i don't know
how many of you have played the super
mario party on nintendo switch which is
a good game to play with your friends so
you're on islands you
toss a die to decide how many steps you
can move forward and then you are going
to encounter treasures and monsters
we don't have any of those fan stuff
here this is very basic so we are just
given this a simple map and you are
starting from the the source and you are
going to the destination okay so you can
choose which edges to go through on this
graph and different edges are associated
with the different amounts of rewards as
you can see here
so you want to
go you want to pick the path so you can
collect the most reward here okay
so um as you can see like it is pretty
easy to see that here uh this is perhaps
the optimal path here okay so you can
collect the most reward uh but of course
this is the game so you cannot always
get what you want so the rule of the
game is um at each at each location so
for example suppose you are here then if
you choose uh to go up
then like you are you are
through this upper range uh with
probability point six uh but still with
point uh probability point four you may
go down okay and similarly if you choose
to go down it says i want to go down but
only with probability 0.6 you're going
to go down and with the rest of the
probability you're going to go through
the upper rank okay so there's a
randomness here okay so then what should
we do here you may want to say okay we
still we may still want to try to follow
this path over here right so suppose we
are at the beginning we try to go up but
because of the randomness we may end up
like
being here and if we are here um then
what to do okay so we actually need to
know which actions to choose uh for
every location here so we need a
contingency plan for us to decide where
to go okay so then like uh with this in
the with this randomness in mind let's
look at this problem again it may seem
pretty complicated because you you don't
always end up going the place you you
want it uh so but it becomes very easy
if you actually look at this problem
backwards if you start from the the end
okay so here if we start from the end
this is the location here uh here we
don't have any choice so if you are here
the reward you are going to get in the
future is definitely two right because
like there's only one link to go to the
destination and then similarly here is
six okay so now let's move to here
okay so here then uh we know that like
uh if we if we end up going uh going
through this thing then we have an
instantaneous reward that's equal to one
here and once we are at this stage we
have a future reward that's two so the
total reward is going to be three if if
we end up going through here okay and
the total reward is going to be eight if
we end up going here so then like it
seems like so then
uh if we choose to if we prefer to go
down that would be the better choice
right so we can actually calculate the
future reward once we are here okay so
if we try to go up then with the
probability of 0.6 we're going to go
through the upper link we get a total
reward of three if we try to go down uh
this is what we are going to get
and um if i remember correctly this is
going to be five and then if we go down
uh similarly with the probability point
four we're going to go up and with the
probability of this we're going to go
down and this ends up to be a better
option okay so here we should go down
and then make this number six here is
the best reward expected reward you can
get if you are if you are in this
location so i'm going to write it here
i'm going to call this the value of
those locate of this location
okay and similarly we can see like here
is eight and then like once we are uh
here
now again that we can try to decide and
the the uh
the the immediate reward on the upper
link case higher but if we go uh go to
this location here then the total reward
is actually going to be lower okay so
the app so the up uh the better option
is actually to go down it's different
from the deterministic path okay so the
better option here is to go down and
i think uh i forgot what this i think is
for 8.6 if if we calculate the expected
reward and this is
8.2 if i remember correctly you can
check the numbers and then you can also
like move on to the first stage and the
first the source and then like
going up is the better option here and
then like you can also work out the
total reward okay
okay so in this example we can see like
the uh the important concepts in the
markov decision process so basically
what we have is we have state which is
the location on this graph in this
example and we have action which is up
and down right and then like once we
know our current state and we take an
action that decides the distribution on
the next state so we have those
transition transition probabilities okay
and also we have a reward function the
reward is a is
the distribution of the instantaneous
reward depends on the state and the
action you take
and what we want to do is to
have a policy which which decides which
action to take at each state and we want
to find the policy that maximizes the
total reward okay
um and in this particular example we
have a so-called finite time horizon
because the things just end like after a
finite number of time steps so next i'm
going to give you the
general notation for a markov decision
process and i'm also going to just
extend the timeline to infinity so we
are going to deal with the infinite time
horizon problem here okay
um so in this particular example it
doesn't have a loop but in general of
course you can have loops you can have
if you then like
yeah so you could have loops in the
graph
okay um
okay so um in
so for a general mdp it's specified by
several things like we said we have the
state space
we use of t to denote the state at time
t this is a discrete time process
and we have action space we have action
at time key and uh just for simplicity
for for the purpose of this tutorial we
are going to assume that the state space
and the action space are uh finite so
they have uh their cardinalities are
finite and uh um this is the most common
assumption but uh there are work that
can extend those assumptions to like
infinite space and infinite
action space we're not going to go down
there there
the proofs there may be different from
what we are seeing here okay
and then as we said once we have a state
under action that decides the
probability of transitioning to the next
state so we have this those transition
probabilities
and also we have our reward function as
a function of s and a and uh when it is
random we just write this like to mean
its expectation okay so we are because
usually we think about the expected
reward
okay
so
uh is the notation clear
yeah
okay so uh once um
so now let's talk about the policy uh so
in general the policy decides what
action we take at each time step it
could depend on the history like all the
actions rewards and states in the past
but here we are going to just focus on
what's called the stationary policies
so um then
the policy is denoted as pi so then like
our action a at time t is only going to
be determined by the state at time t so
we are on making decision only based on
the current state okay and in general
this action could be randomized so this
is a uh
this
a sub g just follows this distribution
determined by the current state okay
okay so um there's a reason that we
consider stationary policies like the
optimal policy can be shown to be a
stationary policy we're not going to go
there so let's
just think about stationary policies
here okay
um so then our goal is to find the
policy to maximize this objective
function over here
so the is there a question
no
um okay so the objective here first as
we said we are dealing with the infinite
time horizon so we are summing up the
rewards from time zero to time infinity
um but we are discounting the rewards in
the future by this uh factor of
gamma rays to the power of t so the
gamma here
is the is a is a number between zero and
one and it's the discount factor
so
um there are uh different explanations
for this
so we can say okay the reward in the
future is not as important as the reward
now so we are discounting the reward in
the future or like we can think of um
this
uh gamma here as the probability for the
problem to continue after each time step
so then like
the then the the gamma addresses to t is
the probability of
still having the problem at time step t
okay
okay so and this so this is our
objective function this is the total
discount reward um and uh this
we are we want to maximize this with the
initial state s here okay so we want to
do this actually for all the states
okay then this objective function is a
function of the
the
initial state so this will be pi of s we
call this the value function
the function of policy pi
okay
okay so now we have defined our goal um
how can we find the optimal uh optimal
policy
so
a starting point is to review
uh this example we had at the beginning
so there we looked at the problem
backwards right we start from the the
last time step and
go backwards
of course with the infinite time horizon
we don't have the last time step per se
but the following idea still works
so here we actually mark the number on
each state that's the optimal reward in
the future if you are in that state okay
and when we make the decision we kind of
sum up the instantaneous reward and the
optimal future reward and then like make
our decisions based on that okay so that
idea still applies to the internet time
horizon problem
so basically what we want to do is if we
our current
current state
is s
okay
and
if we know if we know the optimal
optimal future reward
um
of each state so we call that we start
of the state let's call it s prime so
this is like for all the s prime in the
state space okay so then what we want to
do is we want to look at each action and
then like if we take action a this is
the instantaneous reward and then we
have the future reward right if we end
up in states um as let's say the state
in the
assets of our initial state this is like
initial state and we want to look at our
um states in the next time step okay and
once we take action um once we take
action a
this gives the distribution sorry this
is a
this gives the distribution of the next
state so we can take the expectation of
that
and we need to discount it by a factor
of gamma so then this is the the overall
the total discounted reward if you take
action a right and then like if we
maximize over this maximize over a
then um this should be our best option
and this should be the optimal reward
our optimal total reward and again
because the we we've already denoted the
total optimal uh sorry the optimal total
discounted reward as we start so this
actually should just give us back v star
of s because now we start from state s
okay and this should be true for every s
okay so what we just did was we just
wrote down a series of equations
for this function v star right so the v
star is the optimal uh we call this v
star optimal
value function
it's it's the is the uh optimal future
reward and then this equation is is the
the well-known bellman equation
or like on the dynamic programming
equation okay
okay so um yeah we just derived this
based on our intuition is this correct
um it is so it can be proved in this
theorem which says the optimal value
function this dark indeed satisfies the
bellman equation
and uh
and then like when we do this
maximization here if we take the
maximizer at each state that gives us
the optimal policy pi star
okay
so um
yeah so so we are assured that like uh
the bellman equation indeed as true and
i'm going to skip the proofs here okay
so now let's see what we can uh so now
we have this equation uh oh i guess i i
need to measure one more thing okay so
let's say you're going to give
right so uh
yeah so basically so this is this is a
heuristic here so in the proof what we
can show is we can we can derive this
like we can say that
um so first so we can we can show that
this v star here is um upper bounded by
the right hand side because like here so
that is related to what i'm going to
tell you next so we can actually write
down a similar equation for any policy
and then like you can optimize the
policy so you get one direction of the
of the inequality here
and another direction can be uh can be
get by saying okay so
um if i have some um
i have if i have some uh policy here i
can improve i can basically
do better if i do a maximization at the
current step so with those two things
combined we have the equality here
yeah these are unique is it obvious yeah
that's i'm going to answer that in a
minute okay uh
okay
other questions
okay so um
so yeah the next thing that it's it's
used in the proof and also it's just
uh
important to know uh we not only have
this equation for the optimal policy if
we are we have a fixed policy pi we also
have the equation here so basically what
this says is if you have a policy pipe
uh the value function for pi like we we
denoted by v super pi here and this is
the um
value the the total discount discounted
reward you get if you start from state s
and follow the policy pi okay and then
nega is equivalent to say okay so the
current the instantaneous reward is
giving is given by uh just this right
like we have state s we have action
given by the policy and then like plus
the future reward is going to be
discounted by the vector gamma and is
going to be v pi of s1 and now this this
expectation here um we draw our action
from
the policy
uh
when we start from s and our next state
follows the transition
uh distribution here if we do state s
and we start from a okay so this is the
the equation for fix the policy pi okay
and uh um
yeah as as we as we said like if you do
the optimization over the action here
like if we do the optimization it's
going to be uh larger than what we have
here and that gives us like one side of
the inequality for the bellman equation
for the optimal policy
okay
well it's sort of clear because this
whole thing is set up
you need to prove that actually there
might not be a global policy which is
better than just taking the next step
um so although it's just the next step
but all this this thing here already
encompasses all the future information
here so if we are using the optimal in
the future then like this this one step
is already out today let me ask it
differently
um
right
yeah then that could be a delay
of two
different states of the
world and that i can't see it locally
but if i took a global view i would
realize oh if i choose this path and
then more likely i'll end up in this
state of the world if i do this past i
end up more largely in that
[Music]
you can already see that at the
beginning of the example so uh like if
you uh so
here like if
basically what you're saying is like
uh if you can see long enough in the
future you you you may want to choose
between if you are here you may want to
choose between those two states and
although like currently this one is not
good enough the instantaneous reward is
not good enough but in the future this
is a better location because in the
future it's going to be pretty good so
that's already
like kind of encoded in the
manufacturing no i'm asking a stupid
question which some of them is
you could encode
the state that you're in if you that
made one decision three steps ago it
would be a different state from where
you are right now
if you are
and in fact this is the semi-proof that
she mentioned so if you start from a
non-stationary policy you can locally
improve that get the station policy that
you have here administration course is
the one that probably doesn't change
over time
yeah so so there are like two steps to
the proof first you can prove that you
don't need to depend on the whole
history you only need to depend on the
current state and then there's another
step of the truth which says you you can
do just the same thing for every time
step so it's stationary so i actually
skipped it
on the first step so like the first step
i kind of skip that yeah we can talk
more later yeah
okay uh
okay so yeah let's see where we are
um
okay so we just uh okay we just showed
the bellman equation and we have the
batman equation for fixed policy okay so
let's look at the spelman equation so uh
how can we make use of this to give us
the optimal policy right so
naturally we just want to we want to
solve this to get our v star and then
make our best policy out of it and then
make it to make this work we need to
answer the following two questions
related to jackie's question so first if
we indeed find the solution is it
guaranteed to be restart so is the
solution unique
and the second question is like how do
we exactly get the solution right so um
to answer both questions it's convenient
to rewrite the bellman equation in the
following way so uh if we look at the
right hand side of the bellman equation
so basically we
give the the right hand side a value
function in this case is the v star here
and it's going to output a function of
the state right so this this is true for
every state
so basically the run high side
takes a value function as an input and
outputs another value function
okay
so
uh to make that clearer let's say like
since our state space is finite without
loss of generality we just index it in
this way okay and then like a value
function is a function of s so we can
think of this as just a vector like this
sorry v 1 through vd
okay
and then
um
we can look at this right hand side here
okay so it takes a very function v
star here and it outputs um we we call
sorry this this whole thing including
the maximization here okay
so we are
when we are doing the outside the right
hand side we are applying operator t on
our value function v star okay and this
uh this operator then is a
mapping from this rd to rd okay and then
like for any v
in
rd
the output tv
is also a
vector in rd so if we look at the s
value at s it's basically just like the
right hand side okay so let me write it
again
[Music]
okay so um yeah this is how we define
this operator key and then with this
defined we can just like rewrite the
bellman equation in the following way so
it's basically v star is equal to t v
star and when we want to solve this
equation basically we want to find the
fixed point
of t right
okay
so uh once we see it through the this
perspective of the operator sorry good
yeah question
uh s1 is the state at the time step one
okay so we are like let's say our
initial state is s then like s1 is the
next state um its distribution is
determined by your current state and
your current action
okay so yeah um so once we we view this
from the uh so this key is called the
bellman bellman operator um
then
once we write it in this way uh we can
use um
the uh the contraction mapping theorem
to uh answer those two questions at the
same time okay so first let me just give
you the uh definition of a contraction
mapping so a contraction mapping is
mapping on the metric space let's say we
have a complete metric space here the
space is x and the d is the distance is
the metric on the space and then like we
say a mapping t is a contraction mapping
if there's a
less smaller than one such that when you
uh
when you apply the mapping on two points
you contract their distance by a factor
of alpha okay so um yeah so basically
the distance between two points becomes
smaller once you apply the the mapping
okay and um again we like uh if we have
an equation like this basically x star
is called the fixed point because after
you apply it it's still there okay
um so now uh we have uh once we have a
contraction mapping we have this theorem
that answers like a kind of the two
questions we wanted to ask so if you
have a contraction mapping on a complete
metric space then the fixed point is
unique okay
and so we have a unique fixed point and
moreover uh we can actually find the
fixed point using the
iterative algorithm here so you can
start from any point and you just keep
applying the operator and it's going to
converge to the fixed point okay and it
converges exponentially fast basically
after every step you are alpha closer to
the fixed point okay so then you can
show that the distance just decreases
like exponentially faster in this way
and a slightly more useful band is this
one uh so you can measure the distance
between x k and x star using uh the
distance between x one and the x
x naught okay so it's slightly more
useful because like here you you don't
know where x star is so you don't know
like it was the decent distance between
x zero and x star okay
okay so
yeah so then like uh if our bellman
operator is a contraction mapping of
course like
everything is good right we can just use
this algorithm to find the optimal uh
value function and is it well low and
behold it is so we can actually
formally show that the bellman operator
is a contraction mapping and the the
discount factor is the contraction
coefficient here okay
so um and the distance here is uh we we
need to this theorem holds for the
infinite uh norm so the distance is
induced by the infinite norm so the
infinite norm is basically the maximum
absolute value of all the coordinates
okay um
okay so this is this proof is actually
very easy to uh to do so uh let's do
this really quickly it's just a couple
of lines okay so suppose we start from
any state in the state space
okay and then let me write out what's
the uh
if we are given any two arbitrary value
functions v1 and v2 let me look at the
distance once we apply the bellman
operator okay
and then by definition this is going to
be
max over all the action r as a
plus uh gamma
u of
v1 s1
okay this whole thing
okay and then minus basically the same
thing but the uh with v2 plugged in so
i'm going to just copy it
here
okay
let's do v2
okay so this is just the definition and
then
for the first the maximization here
let's say it's achieved
achieved at
a star okay
because our action space is finite so
it's quite easy to do this proof here
otherwise you need to do a little bit
more work
okay so if this is achieved at a star
then this whole thing if we plug in the
star is the maximum is the maximize the
value and if we plug in a star here it's
not going to be as good as the maximum
value right so then like this
then this maximum value is larger than
uh the thing with a star plugged in so
the whole thing is upper downloaded by
r
sp star
so this is the first line with a star
plugged in
this one
star and then the next line is upper
bounded by the thing with a star plug in
like this
and then the the first the instantaneous
reward cancels
um and then like we are left with the
rest and as you can see here uh we are
doing the difference between two
functions v1 and v2 okay and then we
take the expectation right
but because of our definition of the
infinite norm here is the maximum value
so for any state s1 the difference here
between v1 and v2 is going to be upper
bounded by the infinite norm of their
difference
okay
so so then the whole thing is going to
be absolutely by
the gamma times just v1 minus v2 in the
norm um the expectation like is just
average like for any next possible state
is upper bounded the difference is upper
bounded by the infinite norm okay so the
whole thing is upper bounded by this
okay
and also you can do the other direction
showing that if you do tv two minus tv
one is upper bounded by this so the so
then like basically we have to prove
that this contraction here
okay so this is the kind of the most
important property of the bellman
operator um so now like it's a
contraction mapping we can apply uh this
algorithm given by the contraction
mapping theorem so this is the so-called
value iteration so basically you start
from any value function and then you
keep applying the bellman operator and
uh
it's going to con until it converges of
course in practice we need to stop the
algorithm at some point so if we stop it
at time k then vk is what we get and
by the contraction mapping theorem we
know that vk is going to converge to v
star and we can even bound their
difference um and then like once this is
our output we can get the policy by just
applying like
uh by taking the maximizer on the right
hand side of the
bellman operator of the belmont equation
okay
so then like the natural question is how
good is this pi k uh this is uh i'm not
going to show it here but basically we
should bound the v pi k and the
difference between those two
and
it's going to be apprehended by this
plus
v k
minus v star and
this part is upper bounded by the
contraction mapping theorem this part
can also be bounded because our pi k is
kind of derived from vk
okay and the whole thing like you can
show that it's going to be
bounded by something like this
okay
okay so it it does converge and we know
that we can bound the difference here
okay
okay so this algorithm it kind of
centers around value function we first
look at the optimal value function and
then we make the policy out of the
function okay so next i'm going to talk
about another
algorithm that's more centered around
the policies themselves
so this is the uh so-called policy
iteration algorithm so in this algorithm
we want to focus on the policy so we
start from a policy and we evaluate the
current policy and then next we improve
the policy based on our evaluation right
so it generally has those two steps and
uh
many uh reinforcement learning
approaches kind of
follows this like a kind of two-step
approach
so uh in in our case here this is a very
basic version so the value evaluation
here basically is just like we want to
calculate uh the the value function
of a policy uh policy pi okay and then
like when we do the policy improvement
we want to make use of like we want to
make use of the behavior equation
okay
so to make this more concrete um let's
first
uh let's first define another operator
okay which i promise is really useful
when you when we look at the proof okay
so for any fixed policy pi uh we know
that this is our
equation for the policy pi this is what
we have seen before and we are going to
just like how we define the development
operator so here we are also going to
define an operator associated with this
policy pi okay so we are going to call
the right hand side t pi applied to
uh the value function v pi okay
so then the function this uh
this equation can be written as
v pi is equal to t pi
v pi
okay
so another is also like a the fixed
point of
t pi and we can we can show that we can
show that
t pi is also a contraction mapping
okay and it also has like a gamma as the
the contraction coefficient which is of
a discount sector okay so then this
means that if you just start from any
value function if you keep applying this
uh operator t pi here you are going to
get the value function of the policy pi
okay so this is how we do our policy
evaluation we basically just still make
use of the contraction mapping theorem
and we will converge to the value
function of pi
okay
and
another
important property is that like both the
t pi
and the bellman operator t they are
monotonic
okay so basically if we have uh two
value functions
uh v1 which is smaller than v2 at every
state then when we apply this
operator it's going to keep this
relationship
okay okay so uh this is pretty easy to
show so let's just keep that in mind
they are monotonic okay so now we have
figured out how to do the policy
evaluation let's do the policy
improvement okay so the policy
improvement like we said we are going to
uh make use of just the right-hand side
of the bellman equation so if our
current policy is pi k so what we are
going to do is let's look at um
this instantaneous reward
and we think about the pi pi k here
we think about the uh better function of
pi k
as our future
uh reward
and uh then
if we
image imagine that in the future we have
that reward and now if we maximize over
the action a
um this is going to give our
give us our next policy okay so if we do
this this is our pi k plus one
uh at
state s
okay so we basically just plug in this
and then like the maximizer gives us the
next policy okay so if we look at this
then basically the property we have here
is that on the right hand side we are
just applying the bellman operator to
the value function v of pi k because we
are doing the maximization right so this
is just the development operator applied
there okay and because this is how we
defined our policy pi k plus one so
basically what we have is like um when
we take the maximizer is going to
if this is achieved at a star that's
going to that star is the action we are
going to take based on pi k plus 1 right
so that means the right hand side also
is the uh bellman operator
of uh
sorry the the the operator associated
with pi k plus one applied at this value
function
okay
so this is the property we are going to
need in the proof okay so um yeah you're
going to see this again
okay okay so now let's put everything
together so this is just a a reputation
of what we have seen so far we start
with any policy we evaluated the policy
by computing its uh value function and
then we update the policy in this way
and we keep doing this until we converge
okay
so um does it converge uh we have this
theorem that shows that it's going to
converge within a finite number of steps
okay so basically the theorem says after
every step
we actually indeed improve our policy
okay so the value function becomes
larger at every state
okay
and if it doesn't improve anymore then
we have we we then the the policy is
already the optimal policy okay so
because we assume a finance disk space
and finite action space the number of
possible policies is actually um uh
finite uh so then like with the with
those two two properties uh then like uh
we are going to just convert within a
finite number of steps right like every
step we eliminate one uh uh so the the
the number of policies better than the
current policy decreases right
okay
so
okay so let's see a quick proof of this
theorem
like we said the core of the algorithm
is the policy improvement step
and the improvements that step like we
said we have this equality here
this is just a given by how we
do the policy improvement
okay
and now because we are doing the bellman
operator right we are picking the
optimal action
so
that's going to be better than that's
going to be better than
the action you you pick according to pi
k
okay
so
if you take action according to pi k
then the total reward you are going to
get is just the value of pi k right so
this is going to be larger than v of pi
k
okay
okay so this is kind of the the the the
inequality we are going to uh make use
of so we have this and then like we have
the monotonicity so if we apply pi k
plus one again
okay pi k plus 1 between pi k
it's going to be
uh larger than this
sorry
i k plus 1
b pi k
okay and then like you which is larger
than this right
okay so because of the monotonicity and
we can keep applying this operator here
okay so then what we are going to get is
this if we apply it in times
then what we have is this right
and then if we take n goes to infinity
then as we said like here this operator
associated with any policy is a
contraction mapping
so when we take n to infinity no matter
where we start what we get is going to
be just the value function of this
policy which is the policy pi k plus one
okay so then this is a going to converge
to v pi k plus one
okay so then we get uh our improvement
here
this equality then we are good actually
so that's the second
uh
statement in the theorem if we are if
it's inequality then we actually get our
optimal policy so to see that
okay uh let's still do this we have this
uh let's start from here
okay i'm going to copy it here so we
know this is true okay
now if our
we have an equality here then that means
if we do the uh
t pi k plus 1
v pi k plus 1
is going to be equal to v pi k plus 1
right
because of the equality
and then like
this this is exactly equal to v k plus 1
right so then basically what we know is
v k plus 1 is this
okay so we k plus 1 actually satisfies
the bellman equation so it is the
optimal value function
okay
so um yeah so this is the the policy
iteration algorithm and we just showed
that it actually works um yeah
so why is this you have to
include the algorithm stopping the
finite number of steps oh yeah so with
this like we need so in the so that's
that holds for finite state space and
finite action space
but like every time you so if we so if
we have a finance space and find the
action space so the total number of
possible policies is just finite okay so
you have a finite number of policies and
you are doing better and better
until like you find the optimal one so
the so every time you kind of you either
go to a different policy or you stay the
the same if you stay same you're already
the optimal one if you go to a better
policy you are eliminating one of the
better quality you are reducing the
number of policies that are better than
you
takes
number of steps
yeah like it just says it's finite
yeah i can remove something bad
um i'm not sure
yes
okay so there's one more thing i want to
mention so we can also so that helps us
transition to the
next part of the tutorial so
um i'm going to introduce the notion
called the true function
um so the motivation is like this so
first let's look at our bellman equation
is written in this way right so now if
we are given the optimal value function
v star if we want to
get the optimal policy then we need to
solve this maximization problem here so
the optimization problem here
if we want to solve it it requires us to
know the the transition probabilities
right so then that we can actually write
out the right hand side so solving this
some of this requires
like knowing
uh the transition
the transition probabilities okay
and
if we don't know that like it's hard
like to get the policy even if we have
the optimal value function
so uh what can we do like this seems
like a trick at the beginning so
if we indeed have direct access to this
whole thing on the right hand side let's
say we call this we call this uh
this is a function of both the state and
action so we call it a function q okay
if we directly know the q function here
then of course our v star as will be
just the maximum
over a and the q s a
right
um so then like we can we can uh we we
can we can solve this optimal
optimization problem directly
um
so
of course like this q function then like
in
in reinforcement learning setting where
you don't actually know the model there
are different ways to learn the q
function and once you learn the q
function it's easy to get the policy
okay and uh so let's just see what the q
function like does the q function
satisfy a similar equation like the
bellman equation right um it's actually
quite easy to see based on the
definition our q function
is this r s a
plus gamma
this here and then we can replace the v
star with the q function so it's going
to be max
a q
let's call this a prime as a prime okay
and then times the transition
probability
of course like if you directly look at
the right hand side if you want to
evaluate
evaluate it it still needs the
probabilities but there are other ways
to learn the cube function in
reinforcement learning okay
um so this is the this is actually the
the this is called the optimal q
function what does it mean so basically
uh
it means that
it is the total discounted reward if you
take action a at the current stack
but you take the optimal policy in the
future okay so all the future actions
follow the optimal policy except for the
current step the current step you take
action a okay so that's the meaning of
the uh the q function and if this is the
optimal policy this is the optimal q
function so similarly we can define the
the q function
associated with the
with the policy pi
so this is going to be the uh so q super
pi here
this is going to be the total discounted
reward if you take action a at the
current step
but you take the
uh take actions according to the policy
pipe in the future okay so in the future
the value you get is like this
okay and then nikki um there's also a
relationship between the q function
associated with pi and the value
function for pi because like um the
difference is just in the current step
so if you take you indeed take the
current action based on your policy then
again like you you the total discounted
reward will be the total discounted
reward of the policy pie right so then
that means if we take the the q function
here
and
we
do the expectation by saying okay a is
drawn from the policy pi
okay so then this should give us our v
pi
okay so um yeah this is going to be
useful in the next part of the tutorial
okay um
yeah so with this um
yeah this is the last page of my
note i don't have a conclusion page uh
so any uh i'm going to just stop here
any more questions
so what does q a stand for
i don't know
really quiet
you didn't have the discount like can
you consider like a infinite average
award right yes that's mentioned so
there are other choices of the objective
function so you could do the average
reward over infinite time horizon and uh
without the same results
and not exactly some results will
continue to hold some will not and the
troops are
usually going to get very technical and
uh you cannot do the direct validation
you need to do a relative better
iteration to make it work
that's a little bit of advertisement for
friday i think but um
since you asked about the infinite
version here's a
amazing fact about this problem so if
you look at everything i did but imagine
you take gamma to one
after sometime the policy is going to
freeze
you do not change the policy after a
certain body of dharma
and so in some sense
after a high enough discount factor
nothing changes
there's something called the blackboard
optimality
this would be one of the first
great results in this area a bit of an
advertisement for friday's
thoughts
but you can you have the things to
actually prove that now to the more they
can
understand
and this is just a one tiny bit
you mentioned that this q function could
be bypassing the probabilities but it's
not explicit from this formula
right so yeah
if you look at the queue function so
that can be directly estimated from your
data pieces for example
so then like that way you you kind of
estimate it based on like the states uh
actually transition the the state
transitions you can see from the data
and then they get yeah then you can
directly learn the two functions
and why is that different from the valid
function like why just by looking at
these equations that's not obvious
yeah it i i mean uh it's just like uh
let you get the policy more directly
yeah i guess because we can't have more
insights on this what was the questions
here so why just from this
transformation i can see that modeling
the q function might be useful
for me not to have to learn these
probabilities
so the q function also satisfies much
more integration
that
for value function you need to do an
optimization
so it's really depending
so you cannot swap the max and
expectations so it's not easy to get
that known by assessment for the value
function before the q function changes
there's a
yeah that's the equation for 200 but
this step doesn't need an expectation
there
yeah
okay
for the i'm talking about the q of pi
what a cube
nice
for that one you can just take the
sample fact
and that gives you another basis later
even for v of pi still
here's max
max
yes
[Music]
nobody doesn't have together